[Musique]
le musée des beaux-arts et vite montréal
autant de la portée ni à s'évader vers
paris au temps du post impressionnisme
on peut se transporter dans le paris de
la belle époque on peut découvrir toute
l'avant-garde artistique avec les noms
les plus célèbres qui soit que ce soit
signac monnaie redon denis vallotton
toulouse lautrec picasso bref tout le
monde est là au coeur de l'exposition
l'artiste paul signac co fondateur du
salon des indépendants
à la fin du 19e et au début du 20e
siècle ce groupe d'artistes souhaité
exposer librement sans jury ni
récompense
on était à une époque de progrès de
progrès social
paul signac et est un anarchiste c'était
un homme engagé et donc il ya vraiment
participer à tout ce mouvement de
revendication et à tous moments de foi
et d'espoir où on penser que l'art
pouvait amener des jours meilleurs
500 oeuvres exceptionnelles qui ont vu
le jour à la même époque l'émergence de
syndicats des partis socialistes et de
l'automobile
c'est un moment car beaucoup de liens
avec ce qu'on vit en ce moment au niveau
de mouvement social au niveau des
questionnements des systèmes de
gouvernement une période également où
les femmes artistes ont plu plus de
place on voyait beaucoup d'artistes
femmes qui ont exposé leur art ou salon
des indépendants
on voit aussi dans des expositions des
pionnières artistes femmes comme berthe
morisot qui était est une artiste
extrêmement forte et extrêmement
indépendante
[Musique]
à l'origine l'exposition devait prendre
l'affiché à la fin mars
le collectionneur privé à qui
appartiennent les toiles accepté de
prolonger son prêt et le parcours a été
légèrement modifié en revenant dans les
salles
après la période du coc vide j'ai
vraiment voulu manquer amener de la joie
notamment il ya un mur rose absolument
extraordinaire donc qui permet de
clôturer donc la visite sûr un signe
d'espoir
paris au temps des post impressionniste
c'est une dose de force de liberté et de
beauté ici nabi alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal
[Musique]